If your world was under the
brutal ruling of a ball
dude with powers that are insane as hell.
What would you do?
Someone needs to stop this guy
from becoming the ultimate hero.
Before his carefree attitude kills us all.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do,
and how to beat Saitama in One-Punch.
Man, Riiight.
This freak has no idea that he is about
to get millions of innocent people killed.
And by that
I mean this guy Bald dude, a.k.a.
Saitama, This guy is the world's top
wannabe badass who does hero shit for fun.
And his half assed backstory means
that this guy can get away with defeating
any enemy that tries to destroy Japan
because he's that good with one punch.
But Saitama here started off
as your average dude who spent a few years
doing the basics of functional fitness
to become the universe's strongest hero
wannabe. This is insane training.
So hard that he became bald,
and now he spends his day
sleeping through his empty life
while easily
defeating the occasional villain
that pops up around town until now.
Because all of a sudden, Saitama,
while out shopping, sees this gigantic,
sexy, strong man terrorizing the town
thanks to sexy, strong man's, crazy, mad
scientist brother,
this giant has figured out a way
to become huge, and he's
going to fight against Saitama himself.
Holy shit, that this is insane.
This giant, sexy, strong
man is super sexy.
I mean, look at those muscle insertions.
Look at the striations.
The Cavs could use some work, though.
But anyways, this is perfect.
Giant, sexy, strong man is jacked as hell
and makes me think that his striated
testicles and overwhelming contractile
tissue will be one thing
that we could use to fight Saitama
head on fight fire with fire, baby.
Now, part of what makes Saitama punches
so dang deadly seems to be
because his punches cover such a small
surface area I mean, think about it.
Having a smaller impact area increases
the pressure and lethality of his punches.
But like I said, maybe in this instance,
overwhelming force is what is
needed to take this bald headed superhero
freak on because giant sexy
strongman's brother figured out how
to create the greatest steroid out there.
Which means the first thing I would
definitely not do
is to tell Dom about this guy
because that's a very, very bad idea.
What I would do would be to get to work
on replicating the drug results
that we got on giant sexy strongmen
on onto other test subjects
before we revealed this to the world.
Because in doing so,
we would create an army of sexy, striated,
muscular warriors to fight this bald dude
without us having to lift a finger.
Because screw that.
Have you seen that power off of side
Saitama?
It is off the charts. In no way
would we want to fight this guy head on.
No, no, no, no, no.
We got to find someone else
to do our dirty work.
Now, to build our army,
we have to find the best test subjects
and ideally willing test subjects.
And to make it easy for us,
we should go to every single gym out there
to hunt down every vanity and douchebag
wanting to get big and swole.
And over time, we could build
an army of giant, super sexy, strong men.
With this drug,
we should head up every single Equinox
gym, only to ensure that we've got only
the biggest and most dubious gym brothers
of all time to use in our equipment.
Because anyone who pays
a $300 monthly gym fee to look good
is a certified douchebag.
In my book,
the one thing needed to impact Saitama
or where it hurts
is with our very own sponsor
of today's video.
Genshin Impact.
Genshin Impact is a badass open
world Action RPG available on PC,
PS4, PS5, Android and iOS.
So start your magical adventure
on the continent of table,
where you'll have control
over one of seven elemental powers
and with three regions to explore.
You can pretty much do anything
in this open world and even cool off
this whole thing
once you reach adventure rank level 16
and this time try to need 2.6.
Update which will feature a new area
called The Chasm,
which is basically a deep hole
with even deeper
underground levels to explore and will
have you using sick gadgets
to help you find a variety of rewards.
All the waiting to be discovered
such as the five star weapon Billet
and an all new name card.
But remember to hit the bathroom early
because this update will also
have you running into a new artifact
and a new quests which will probably keep
you glued to the screen for longer
than your kidneys can hold out.
And this update comes with a new event
called The Hues of a Violet Garden,
a crazy festival
that will take place in Azuma,
where a special storyline
will be presented along with four kinds
of festival games, from capturing
unique landscapes
to getting freaky on an elemental stage.
Or how about testing your sword skills
like this guy?
Basically, there's a ton of events
and games to be had in this new update.
I honestly love Genshin Impact
for being a fun, open world
with sick characters and cool weapons.
Thank you, Genshin Impact,
for sponsoring this video.
Use my link in the description below
to get the games on all your devices
right now. And now back to the video.
This sexy, strong man is strong as hell
and he prepares
to destroy the entire city.
Right in front of Saitama's eyes.
But Sexy Strongman
is way more sexy than smart,
and he kills his brother accidentally.
This angers him,
and he blames Saitama for all of it.
And he throws him a million miles
a minute down into the earth heart.
But all of his throbbing, bulging
muscles is sadly no match for Saitama's.
One punch strike and Saitama are
knocked him out with ease into oblivion.
Later on, Saitama walks the streets
wondering What good is all of this power
with no enemy to match it.
But little does he know that
he'll soon come to regret this thought,
right as he knocks out some random
Japanese villain number 2 here.
Before heading to bed, waking up
and easily defeating even more random ass
enemies in the process, this guy has
become too strong for his own good,
but his wishes for someone more powerful
than him are soon answered
with this mosquito yes,
this tiny little mosquito.
And Saitama is no match against it.
And he tries to swat it,
but it's too damn quick.
Forcing cytometer,
chasing around town like a madman.
Meanwhile, nearby, the horrors for Japan
have started up yet again,
and this mosquito girl begins
commanding an army of mosquitoes
to hunt down people for blood.
Just as this sexy cyborg known as Genos
shows up bar.
He's cool.
This guy is an up and coming hero
wannabe who wants to know about some weird
cyborg dude that he wants to find
and probably kill.
And it's Genos who tries to fight
this mosquito girl by blasting around
with his rocket boosters and shooting off
fiery blast at this creature.
Doing all of this crazy animal shit
until one of his arms
gets torn off, forcing him
to prepare his ultimate weapon.
This insane laser hand thing.
But then all of a sudden, clueless also,
Saitama pops up right behind him
and still on the hunt for that horrifying
little enemy of his the mosquito.
But Genos thinks so.
Tom is just a regular dude
and tells him to run away,
right as Mosquito Girl attacks
the two of them with all of her bugs,
and Genos fires his weapon,
causing a massive explosion to flood
the whole area around them, setting
practically the entire city aflame.
But it's no match for this mosquito girl
as she evolves even further
right in front of their eyes
into a mosquito queen
looking more bodacious and succulent
than a walking strawberry lollipop.
Dang you dumb.
I didn't want to say that
genos is so screwed as mosquito queen lady
takes a swipe at his robot
tummy and is no match for her powers.
Genos prepares for his death.
Right side hammer out of nowhere, pimp
slaps the blood literally right out of
Mosquito Queen Lady back to Mad House
Studios before calling it a day
but naked and his powers
freak the shit out of Genos
and he asks Saitama to become his student
immediately and even randomly and rudely
shows up at his apartment, later
demanding to learn Saitama's strength.
And now we get to hear the prototypical
hero backstory of Genos.
Some dude whose village was destroyed
as he almost died
but he was brought back to life
as a cyborg by some scientists.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I don't care.
And we see Genos sitting there
and wondering if Saitama is also a robot
just like him.
Bud sighed.
Harmon says nope, shocking
Genos to his metallic bone.
And he points out
that must mean that's Saitama must then
just be a regular old bald
dude with superhuman strength.
And this freaks the hell out of side
Saitama because
no one likes to have their bald spot
pointed out.
I know I wouldn't, but I'm not bald.
Okay, this is it.
We got this bastard
dead to rights at this point.
I mean, come on.
It makes sense.
If you think about it,
if we really wanted to defeat
this bald bastard, then all it would take
is a couple of glances
from afar, giving us the full picture
of who Saitama is.
Over time.
And during that time, we'd figure out
that Genos would be our inside man
into defeating his master.
Because even in public,
it would be obvious, seeing that
these two hang out together all the time.
And so with this info, I would send in
somebody preferably nonthreatening
and similar
to Genos age, early twenties, Max,
and would befriend this robot over
time, gaining his confidence
and prying into asking seemingly
innocent questions about his masters.
I Saitama collecting everything he tells
us to find some chink in cytoplasm armor.
And one of the things
that inevitably would have come up
would have been Saitama's appearance
looking ordinary average,
including the fact that he's bald.
And judging by how Saitama reacted to
Genos just now talking about his baldness,
this is one of his weaknesses.
He's sensitive about his hair troubles.
I would then begin figuring out some plan
to lure Saitama in using the promise
that if he does what we say or joins us,
then we would be able to cure him of this
horrible curse known as baldness
and make him feel confident in himself.
Maybe even being able
to go out and date again.
Not that you need to have hair
to feel like a stud, but I would say
having hair sure does help ride Tom out.
We all have excellent head of hair.
My point being
is that Saitama's sure his shit
looks like he could use some help up top
based on how he just reacted
out of the blue
because all of the strength in the world
won't help him grow his hair back.
And this guy seems sensitive as hell.
About his problem.
Genos then mention that it is
his life goal to become a strong Saitama
and they agreed to join forces with Genos
as Saitama student.
Just then Genos sense
as someone about to attack them.
And that's when shit hits the fan as this
grasshopper wannabe monster attacks them
right before Saitama,
one punches him dead.
Then the two take the fight to the streets
with say, Saitama
getting pulled into the ground.
Then another cyborg pops up, forcing
Genos to go hand-to-hand combat with him,
keeping him busy as more bad guys
show up to take these two down.
And this cyborg calls himself
the armored gorilla and tells Genos
that a famous science lab
called The House of Evolution
sent all of these monsters here
and that he better hand side Saitama
over to them or else these two don't know
that this mad scientist wants
Saitama for his crazy experiments
and will do whatever and kill
as many people as it takes
to get him back over to our side.
Thomas that he comes face to face
with the horrifying beast king
as this lion threatens
to take out his eyes, causing, say,
Saitama, to get semi-serious for once
in his boring life and put on his big boy
pants, dodging every attack
that this beast king throws at him.
His powers are horrifying,
but it's no match for this bald dude's
overpowered moves.
Saitama then performs one of his signature
moves on him, consecutive normal
punches, beating him with ease
along with his small friend.
Genos, then holds this gorilla
dude hostage and interrogates him on
what this mysterious house of evolution
wants with Saitama.
And this gorilla guy finally breaks
and he tells him that his boss
wants to use Thomas body
for his experiments.
On Evolving the human species by Genos
and Cytometer decide to take the fight
to this mad scientist immediately
because there's a shopping sale
that said, Saitama has to get to today
before it expires or else.
Back at the House of Evolution,
this mad scientist is on a whole
nother level of crazy, and he worries that
these two heroes will ruin his evil plans
to perfect the human species.
And he orders his clones
to go and prepare their strongest fighter
to take on Systema carnage.
Kabuto, the strongest fighter they have
but is totally insane.
The next day, Sidearm UN Genos
reached the House of Evolution.
But Genos decides that efficiency is king
and proceed to blast the entire building
to smithereens. Before size time.
I can even get a word in, but in doing so,
they find a secret trap door
leading to an underground facility
and the two head down to investigate.
Not even a second passes by, it seems,
before Carnage Kamado shows up to kick
Genos ass,
embedding him into the side of the wall.
He and Saitama then decide to take
the fight to the science lab special room.
The Combat Experimentation Room,
and the two prepare to battle it out.
But all of a sudden a damaged Genos
unleashes a fiery blast at carnage.
Unfortunately, though, carnage
his lungs are freakishly strong and blows
the fire right back at Genos
cooking Genos good, but in doing so,
ruining Genos hair and turning his hair
into looking similar like popcorn
or broccoli and Carnage beats Genos down
good, and Saitama gets slightly excited
at the thought of finally fighting
a real enemy.
Carnage then tries to attack Saitama,
but his spidey senses
tells him to back the F off
because his animal instincts know
that there's more to say Saitama
than meets the eye,
even though Saitama looks like
he's full of open holes and exposed
his instincts are demanding
that he gets out of there.
He then demands Cytometer.
Tell him how he got so freaking strong,
making everyone in this room
shut up and listen in, hoping to know
the secrets behind Saitama strength.
And that's when Saitama tells them
the secret as to how he got so frickin
strong, starting with 100 pushups,
100 sit ups, 100
squats, and a ten kilometer run
every single day for three straight years.
That's his secret.
And he's totally surprised that
no one believes him, and his perceived
bullshit pisses off carnage so much who
evolves into an even more horrifying beast
and he tries to kill Saitama like crazy
until Saitama realizes
that something very important
today is Saturday.
Carnage will go on a rampage
for a whole week.
Meaning if he fights him for a whole week,
he's going to miss the bargain.
Day at the supermarket,
forcing this bald badass
to lose his shit in anger and rage.
And quickly,
one punch is carnage into oblivion.
But Genos tells him that if they hurry
now, they can make it to the supermarket
before the sale ends
and the to rush off, leaving this dude
even more confused than ever before.
Okay. Okay.
We just found the most invaluable piece
of information folks
that we could use to stop this bald
bastard for good.
If I'm this scientist, I would give up
what I'm working on and work instead
on getting even more filthy rich
because everything is sexier with money,
money, money, money, money.
We just noticed.
That's saitama headed for the hills
and gave up everything.
When he realized that he was going
to be late for that supermarket.
Sale, which means that this guy really
likes buying store shit on discount.
Which totally makes sense
because a bargain is a bargain, folks.
But that means we could use this to time
our robberies to the days
when the town supermarkets
have the biggest sales, which would draw
Saitama attention away, which, oddly
enough, only seems to be on Saturdays.
However, we obviously couldn't
keep repeating this formula every Saturday
because Saitama would eventually catch on
because he's not that dumb,
which means we need to be careful.
And if we really want to be the top dog,
then I suggest that we play the long game
with Saitama.
Hear me out now.
I would spend the next many months
befriending and or threatening,
depending on how we feel that day.
All the supermarket owners in Japan
and in doing so, I would control literally
all the available market outlets
and effectively be able to stop
any and all Saturday sales in Japan
at the same time.
In doing so, stopping
the one thing that Saitama loves
most discounts and coupons and crap.
And then with all of this power,
I would then do one or two things.
One, I would either
confront Saitama and tell him that it's
because of us that his beloved Saturday's
supermarket sale is over
and use this to make him bend to our will.
Although with this plan
he could lose his freakin mind
and kill us right on the spot.
So if we were worried about that,
I would use my second plan
using my control
over all the supermarkets in Japan.
I would time all of the Saturday sales
to happen on only one side of the country.
Which would keep Sai Saitama distracted.
Like I already said,
while me and my minions
rob all the banks and the rich people
on the other side of the country.
Because even though
Saitama is quick he has been quick enough
to browse the items on sales section
and catch the baddies at the same time,
which means one of these things he's
going to kind of have to slack off on
and based on the look on his face here
after hearing of a sale,
makes me think that there's no way
he'll be able to resist.
The next day rolls around
and sighed Thomases on the news
that there's a new baddie in town
that looks eerily like him,
this horrifying and downright
ugly person known as Hammerhead.
But Saitama
can't be bothered to deal with it yet
because, hey, they're low level thugs
until he finds out that they're bald
just like him.
Which obviously means that they stole
Saitama's signature look rude, freaking
Saitama the hell out, which means it's
time for these bad guys to go.
Meanwhile, across town, these bald baddies
continue to terrorize the street
until the best of the worst of the city's
heroes comes rolling in on a bicycle.
It's Mumen rider.
Yeah, known as the Bicyclist for Justice.
And he charges and instantly gets
knocked out like a chump.
Bummer.
These guys continue to terrorize the town
until they run into an actual hero.
This super ninja for hire.
And this guy's aching
to kick some actual ass,
angering Hammerhead and his crew,
and they charge right at him.
But this ninja assassin
wannabe is too dang good and very fast
swinging and sliding through the air
like a long haired captain.
Levi, too quick for any of these bastards
speeding this last guy in under 2 seconds
and showing everyone who the real top
G is around here.
But suddenly the leader of the group
slips away
in a jiffy and bumps
right into Saitama himself.
And of course, cue the mandatory bad guy
punched to Saitama's face,
which is of course, going to do nothing,
which makes Saitama care just enough
to let one mild mannered
punch off on this guy, destroying the bad
guys exo suit and making him run away
butt naked so Saitama
then decides to call it a day
until he runs into Purple Ninja Guy
who tries to attack Saitama at point
blank range at darn near supersonic speed,
confusing the shit out of Saitama,
who he then tells Ninja Guy
that he's got it all wrong.
But this ninja guy doesn't give two shits
because Saitama is bald,
which obviously means
that he's also a bad guy,
and the two prepare
for a showdown of epic proportions.
Okay, this is insane.
Purple Ninja Guy is surely something
if he thinks he can fight baldy over here
head on.
But we can use other resources at our
disposal instead, such as mosquitoes.
Because earlier,
if we remember Saitama couldn't
catch that mosquito to save his life.
And that man has super speed,
for goodness sake.
Why can't he hit a freaking
mosquito is beyond me.
So our best bet as purple
ninja guy would be to drive him mad.
With a bunch of these tiny little suckers.
So I'd call it a day right here with side
and go off into the woods first
to find a bunch of freakin mosquitoes
using some homemade bait
to catch a whole bunch of them, starting
either with some honey juice, sugar,
water, or nectar containing flour placed
within a jar in the corner of a dark room,
leaving it to set overnight
because mosquitoes love sugar.
I would also use everything in our power
to control the situation around us and opt
to fight him in the wee
hours of the early morning
before the sun comes up, when mosquitoes
would be at their most active.
In fact, Mosquito Queen
Bug Lady from earlier should have chosen
to fight early in the morning as well
instead of direct daylight
because direct daylight is deadly
to mosquitoes and can dehydrate them,
which means early morning
we will have an army full of mosquitoes
in our jars and they will be deadly
and charged up on sugar,
ready to buzz around side
timers head until the end of time.
And based on how he handled
that one last bug,
this guy will be chasing them for decades.
Purple Ninja Guy
shows off his incredible speed bud
unfortunately, is no match for Saitama,
who kind of just stands
there and allows his epic fist
to land a blow directly to Purple
Ninja Guys Crunch, causing some epic pain
which caused his problem.
Ninja guy to freak the hell out and run
away like a little bitch loser later
that night.
So Thomas sits and thinks about the most
insane problem he has yet to face,
telling Genos what's on his mind
because no one knows who Zach Saitama is.
He tells journals
that he's defeated hundreds,
if not thousands of the world's
best villains and more
so than anyone else around here.
But still, no one knows who Systema is.
Genos then asks Sai Saitama
if he's signed up
to become a part of the city's hero
registry and mentions that this registry
is a part of Japan's Hero program,
which is sort of like an agency
which lets heroes move up and rank
as they fight more bad guys.
And as they fight more bad guys
through this agency, they'll become more
famous and even gain fan clubs,
which side Tomoe wants desperately lame.
So Genos and Saitama decide
to sign up for fame and glory.
Basically, the next day rolls around
as Saitama and Genos show
up to a hall filled with wannabe heroes,
trying their best
to pass the tests with flying colors
in order to become a hero.
And Genos ends up becoming an S class
hero, which is basically well past
respectable
and entering into an epic class of hero,
allowing him to fight some pretty
terrifying bad guys right from the get go.
Bad I'd to my thanks to as well.
And not so big brain passes
the fitness test by frightening margins
but sucks at the written test
and in doing so puts him in C class
which is the lowest of the low
out of all four classes
bombing the hell out of sitemap
a journalist is such a goody
little two shoes and demands
that Saitama's teach him his fighting ways
regardless and the to the next day
then prepared to go at it
and genos demands that.
So I tell him I'll fight with everything
he's got and Genos
does try really really hard
but he just can't seem to hit
Saitama at all because once again,
Saitama is too quick for Janelle's
stabbing,
just shy of punching his pretty face
into oblivion, blasting
the rock wall behind them into oblivion.
And by the way, parting the clouds
with the sheer force of his punch.
That is terrifying.
And believe it or not,
that was his biggest mistake
because his bad assery only makes a
journalist worship Sai Saitama even more.
Staying with him throughout the night
as Genos bakes to get more info from that
big fat brain upset.
Thomas also mentions
that since they joined the Hero
Registry side harmonies to fight
at least one bad guy weak
in order to retain his hero status
because Genos is an S-Class hero.
So he gets to enjoy some special perks,
such as not having to fight a villain
every week in order to hit a quota.
This causes Cytosol to freak out too,
because if he doesn't hit his villain
quota
every week,
he'll get kicked out of the association.
And that means bye bye fan clubs.
And he also tells Genos to stay put.
So that way Genos doesn't
get any of the credit.
That's item
I should have had when fighting a villain.
So just like a salesman going door to door
trying to sell products, Saitama
runs around the city looking for trouble
in order to fill his quota system.
It looks around for a villain
but can't find one and is super frustrated
suddenly, out of nowhere, Purple
Ninja Guy comes back yet again
and challenges him to a duel.
But side Saitama ignores
him and tells him to go away
while side Thomas looks for a villain,
which of course makes purple
Ninja Guy get really pissed off
and proceed to launch exploding sugar
cans into the buildings and terrorize
the citizens nearby, causing a lightbulb
to go off inside Thomas head and promptly
does a karate chop to a purple ninja guy
in the back of the head, knocking him down
into the ground, thereby filling
Isiah Thomas Birmingham on one bad guy,
a weak quota.
Elsewhere in the city,
the headquarters of Heroes gets word
that the city's most terrifying monsters
are planning something diabolical
and that they can strike at any time.
Horrifying to them
as to what monsters they
and Saitama City will have to face soon.
Suddenly, Japan gets word
that a giant meteor is headed
straight for Japan,
shifting courses at the last minute,
which means that it's going to hit
Saitama's City in less than 30 minutes.
Genos is then secretly called in
and is asked by the Hero Association
if he can do anything about it,
along with this superb, jacked old guy
who tells journalist that
no hero is powerful enough to stop it,
but he is willing to try anyways.
And so is Genos.
They arm up and head straight out and
Genos meets this other hero, metal knight,
who is merely there
to launch a missile up into the air
in order to see how effective
his weaponry is.
My that selfish gentiles
and buff old guy do their best,
but they fail spectacularly and the world
prepares to die right here and now.
And suddenly side Tomoe rolls
in like the frickin stud muffin that he is
and does the most unthinkable thing.
He lets off a more than average
single punch and flies straight
through this meteor, blowing it
the hell up and saving the city.
But unfortunately,
having the debris crash around the city
still causing panic and mayhem.
Bummer.
But on the bright side, this move allows
cytometer bump up from Class
C rank 342 all the way up to rank five.
Unfortunately, though,
the Hero Association is a little bit
suspicious of Saitama's success
and thinks that he had a ton of help
from this guy, which means that Saitama
needs to prove to them
that he's as powerful as he really is.
Saitama then goes for a walk
and runs into six packs stud.
And this guy thinks that Saitama
is taking credit from other superheroes,
punishing him by telling the public
that this bald, overpowered
bastard is a fraud,
making the public hate him.
Okay.
While this simple act might not seem
like much in the grand scheme
of things, this douchebag
who could be onto something here.
Because if we really think about it,
Saitama is overpowered as all hell
and is one of the strongest fighters
in existence out there and dare
I say, of the universe.
However, if it's any indication,
based on how we saw him live his life
so far,
it's safe to say that the man is lonely.
He lacks human connection.
And if it wasn't for Genos,
this guy would likely further
shut himself off from society
if left to his own devices.
Which is why,
if any villain has any sense,
they should work on combating side
armor through brain rather than brawn.
And even at the beginning of the show,
when Saitama met Genos,
he mentioned that nobody knew who he was.
But what if we gave him
what he wants and more?
Because what's worse than being famous,
being infamous?
So this little act of having the public
turn on Saitama could,
in the grand scheme of things, actually
work to weaken PSI Thomas resolve.
If we replicated this numerous times over,
I think we could severely cut Systema
off from the rest of the world
by making the world
hate him forever,
ganging up on him on a global scale
to the point where he would never be able
to make friends or connect
with anyone ever again
because everyone hates him
or is terrified of him.
Either way,
the objective would still be achieved.
And with this approach, we could make
things even more bleak for him by choosing
this guy and planting fake evidence of him
committing even more terrible crimes
to the point where he has no choice
but to go to prison for superheroes.
And while he's in superhero prison,
we will plant even more false narratives
and cause all of the villains in there
to despise him and continually
attack him at every turn in the prison.
And in doing this,
this would make even the most powerful,
even the most invincible of heroes
lonely, eventually causing side Tomoe
to willfully walk away from the world
and shut himself in.
This is how we get rid of Sai Saitama,
forcing him to be despised by the world
forever.
The public quickly
hates on Saitama real hard,
who is not the talk of the Internet
forums,
and everyone thinks that he's a fake.
And these two tank top brothers
challenge cytometer a battle
and of course, predictably get their asses
handed to them with a mere flick of say,
Thomas overpowered the rest and now, say,
Thomas pissed off
and yells to all the public and everyone
starts to get a little bit scared, but
suddenly gentle shows up out of nowhere
to calm Saitama down before Saitama
does something that he'll regret.
And he makes a
I feel a 1% better with the cheesiest bud
kissing you've ever seen, letting Saitama
know that despite all of this negativity,
he'll still follow him to the end.
Elsewhere, the seas begin to rumble
with the most terrifying threat
that this world has ever seen
because the clan of the sea folk
rise up from the shores and are prepared
to kill anyone in their path.
And they proceed to wreak havoc
on the nearby Ocean City and absolutely
destroy their superhero raps
like a mummy holding a spear.
News of the horrors happening
reached by Saitama and journalist.
And they head to the disaster zone
as soon as possible with the Genos
scouting head.
Meanwhile, the Sea
King encounters two more fearless
heroes Purple Ninja Guy and Six Pack.
Well, okay, let's call this Throbbing
Muscles Guy instead.
And these two flecks on this baddie
harder than he's ready for,
but it's still no use.
And they both get their asses kicked hard.
And Genos watches from a distance.
The rain only makes the Sea King
even more powerful than you could possibly
imagine, forcing Purple Ninja Guy
to slip out of his clothes at Escape.
The rest of the public hide in fear
within this giant dome, but it's no use.
The horrifying seeking
finds them and licks his lips in delight.
Who is ready for human sushi?
But all of a sudden
in an act of pure courageousness
and downright hero
cheesy awesomeness, these low ranking
heroes appear from out of the crowd
and are prepared to die for a good cause.
Blah, blah, blah.
Elsewhere, Sai
Tamo looks for trouble but finds a random
phone ringing on the street.
He picks it up and realizes that it's
the Hero Association, and they tell him
that the phone belonged to Mumen Rider,
a hero with a higher ranking than Saitama.
While they tell him that the Sea King
has defeated almost
all of the city's best nearby heroes,
and they tell Sai Saitama
that it's up to him now to save the day,
making this item as ultimate chance
to show off to the world
who he really is, how powerful is,
and that he deserves a class ranking back
at the Dome Genos finally reaches
the crowd of horrified people.
But this creepy ass
Jason Momoa wannabe is downright
horrifying and nasty, and Genos
attacks him with everything he's
got delivering the strength of 10,000 men
upon this Sea King bastard.
But this little girl won't shut her
little trap and causes the Sea
King to decide to live some acidic spit
right onto her face.
But all of a sudden, Genos shields her
using his body,
causing his body to disintegrate
right in front of the girl.
It's disgusting.
And the Sea King has no mercy
and smacks him right out of the dome.
But just then, the famous cyclist
for justice moment, Mumen Rider, pops
back up like a pesky little fly
that won't die
and is prepared to take on the horrifying
seeking right here and now.
And he kills the Sea King.
I know that would have been amazing.
Nope, that does not happen.
The Sea King tosses him aside
like I used Ragdoll butt Mumen riders.
Balls are bigger than rats,
which, by the way, are abnormally large.
It's disgusting.
Human riders courage causes
the seeking to get pissed off
as our cyclists for justice performs
his justice tackle on him.
But this aquatic God has no time for this
pathetic weakling and tosses
movement right back onto the street.
But suddenly
Saitama's shows up out of nowhere,
catching a mid-air, telling him, Good job.
And of course, you know the drill.
The Sea King underestimates Saitama,
who promptly one punches him, causing
everyone to get gob smacked.
The sheer power of Saitama's
punch stopped the weather.
Okay, this is insane.
This stupid Aquaman
wannabe went balls to the wall
with this failed attempt
to take over the world.
He should have, at the very least, done
some recon before breaking land.
And by judging his own big ass crown.
I'm sure he had a servant or two
who would have done some preemptive
scouting for him,
especially if the first city
that you're trying to take over
is known for all of its heroes
flying around in crap.
If he prepared better,
he could have found out where Saitama was,
who he is, and how powerful he is,
and should have known that he can't
take this guy on with brute force,
at least ordinarily.
Which means we got to think smart here.
And also collaboration is key.
This seeking could have partnered up
with that crazy scientist guy
from the house of Evolution
and combined all of his resources
into creating the perfect warrior to fight
Sy Tom ahead on using all of his animals
and insect abilities
that he already has access to,
along with the Sea
King's own DNA being put in there.
And while we're at it,
this Sea King has insane resources
because he's a king after all.
So as the king of the sea,
I would have also raided the city's morgue
to dig up all the dead heroes, steal
their corpses and harvest their genetics.
For our dear scientists
from the House of Evolution,
and throw that into the mix
and creating the ultimate warrior.
Tough fight, Saitama.
Because why is the Sea King fighting?
It's a noble cause,
but I mean, your royalty
let other people do your dirty work. Duh.
The Sea King could have done all of this
if he planned in advance and didn't
just decide to run into a city
and wreak havoc.
Now, the one thing we should address is
why is the seeking a water
creature fighting Saitama on land
and not in the sea?
It's noted that the rain enhanced the sea
king's powers,
which makes me think
how much stronger would it have been
if he chose to lure Saitama into the water
from where he came from?
Saitama strength and abilities
seem to have him rely like all humans
on his sensory glands,
which don't appear to be superhuman.
He doesn't have super smell,
super hearing, and most importantly,
his eyesight seems normal.
And again, like all humans, he relies
on his eyes to see what he's fighting.
And this is where I think his weakness
could be Hear me out now.
Before the land invasion as the Sea King,
I would have kidnaped
dozens, maybe even hundreds of hostages
at night and place them deep
within the ocean at about 200 meters below
and would have got them all suited up
with specialized scuba gear to help them
manage their breathing at such depths.
What?
Many of them die?
Yeah, probably
because they're not like Ahmed Gabbard,
who actually broke the world
record for the world's deepest scuba
dove at 332 meters
or 1000 feet below sea level.
But in summary,
I would bring a bunch of hostages
down into the ocean with me
and for Sy Tomoe to come get me,
because at a depth of 200 meters, Saitama
would have to try and rescue the hostages
within the zone of the sea
called the despotic zone or Twilight Zone,
which is where any such light
would rapidly decrease with depth.
And if we did this at night,
even the faint rays of the moon
would not be able to help him much.
And this would be our opportunity
as the Sea King attacking Saitama
with maximum force
as he tries to save the hostages, Saitama
wouldn't know where we are,
nor what he'd try and fight for fear
of hurting the hundreds of hostages
that surround him.
And with hundreds of people
needing his help
and running out of oxygen, Saitama
would be all alone and unable to see,
giving us the best opportunity
to try and kill him for good
while he's distracted, pressed for time,
and with no one to help him.
And I think this is one instance
where I don't believe he would be able
to simply punch his way out of it.
Everyone here is shocked,
and they think that just maybe
Zatanna Saitama is truly an epic hero.
But that doesn't last
long as the rest of them quickly change
the minds of everyone else saying that
there's no way that a low level hero like
Sy Tomoe could have been the Sea King.
Because look around you,
if a superhero as low a ranking as Saitama
could have been the Sea King.
But that must mean that
all of these other heroes
are weak little pieces of shit, bud
being the little stud that he is.
Saitama takes one for the team and claims
that he got lucky and showed up
at the last minute
when the Sea King was tired,
preserving the integrity of Genos
and every other hero who fought there.
But on the bright side,
Saitama gets promoted to Class C rank one
and gets called in
to the Hero's Association for the chance
to get promoted to Class B and C.
Saitama accepts the challenge,
but a few of the top dogs here thinks that
he's a little suspicious as hell,
and they reveal the tape of his battle
and prepare his evaluation
because site Saitama has no idea
what world he's about to enter.
A few days later, these guys are called
back by the Hero Association
and tells them that they need
to save the earth one more time
because the Hero Association once
had an oracle who recently predicted that
something crazy what happened to the Earth
within the next six months.
But at the last minute,
she died on a cough drop,
making her prophecy even more terrifying
because she died on her own prophecy
and also because she's been right
about her predictions
some of the time, which means
that they could probably maybe be
in deep shit
causing everyone in the room to freak out.
And they prepare for the worst
that is to come.
Just when a rumbling is heard
above them outside and a horrifying alien
ship arrives and Saitama
speedily pops up above them to start
the fight as the citizens begin to flee.
But none of the other heroes
can reach the ship.
So side Saitama, like the overpowered
badass that he is, throws teamwork
right out the window
and head straight into the ship himself.
The aliens inside
freak out as this ship's most fearsome
warrior prepares to take him on side.
Saitama then tries to get into the ship's
command center
the aliens are scared and shit of him,
and they tell him to get out, saying
that the exit is on the right,
not the left, but on the right side.
Tom outsmarts them by going left
while he's so smart
and he finds this alien
God who's mad as hell.
And He unleashes his super telekinetic
gravitational wave
upon our bald
hero, manipulating the forces of gravity.
But Saitama simply thinks that all he is
doing is tossing around a few pebbles,
and Saitama flicks a tiny stone at him
going Mach 500, killing this God
right here and imagines to know
where the real top guy is back on Earth,
the mightiest of heroes fight
the terrifying spawns of this alien race,
just as the ship releases
a massive bombardment upon the city.
Right as this little overpowered
green girl does some crazy animal shit
and sends them right back
using her telekinetic power,
causing even more big booms and the heroes
finally prove victorious,
turning the tide of the battle.
Meanwhile, back on the ship
side, Tom, I finally finds the big boss
dominator of the universe.
This guy called to borrow or we could
call him blue one eyed Cyclops dude.
Probably not moving on.
And he'd tell Saitama
that he's here because of some profit.
I told him that
one day he'd find someone else as strong
as him to fight but Saitama calls him
stupid and punches him, pissing him off
and making him turn into a full on beast.
Holy smoke, Taipan. This guy's insane.
This guy is basically, like, Saitama,
except way more scarier and very cool.
But again, what's with all these villains
just showing
up, expecting to kick some ass
because no one do their homework
on their enemy? Anyone.
If you're following the prophecy
of someone who told you that
you would fight your ultimate opponent
someday and you spent over 20 years
searching for that opponent and found him,
I mean, wouldn't
you be a little cautious
about fighting him?
That's basically
what Burrows is doing right now. Idiot.
Once again, though,
from judging from past fights,
I don't think we'll win this one head
on, folks.
So we need to go through a few options
option one, starting with the famous
Mumen Rider.
Yeah, you heard me.
That guy, what he did brilliantly
when he fought against the Sea King
was his ability to appear unassuming
and not intimidating in the least.
And because of this,
had brought the Sea Kings Guard way down.
Right now, even though the famous
Mumen Rider was actually useless,
the point still stands
borrows should have arrived on Earth
and vetted outside Thomas first.
Then he should have approached the side
Saitama as a friend rather than an enemy,
and offer to help side
Saitama because we've noticed
that side Saitama is bored with life
because he's so dang powerful.
Right.
So what if we came to Earth as sort of
like a missionary goody two shoes
alien and offered to help fix say, Thomas
curse?
He's got a lot of power, right?
He doesn't need all of it.
Why don't we offer to help take some of
his power away so that way he can one day
be more human again and to live a normal,
more fulfilling life.
Think about it.
This guy is so powerful.
Imagine what he must feel like.
If he ever got a girlfriend, he'd worry
about breaking her in half.
With a flick of the wrist. 24, seven.
That sucks.
There's no way
he'd be satisfied as he is right now.
Borrows as a fancy, advanced alien race.
Should have come to see Tom
offering to help reduce his powers
a little by performing experiments on him,
but also in the mean, while secretly
figuring out what makes him so strong.
Performing tests on him
under the disguise of helping him.
And that might be the only way
to know what makes him so damn strong
and the only way to take him down.
Because even that crazy scientist guy
from the House of Evolution couldn't
get Saitama in by force.
So I see with a little delicate
coaxing and lying, we may just be able
to trick our bald, overpowered friend
into letting us help him.
Their battle is epic
and Boras goes full ham on side
Saitama as they battle it out
for the fate of the Earth and borrows
performs his final move on side
Saitama, sending him into space.
But it's no use
because now the universe is mightiest
hero, is tired as hell and is angry.
So aside, Saitama comes down in a jiffy
and repays the favor and unleashes
his serious punch, smacking the shins Ned
right out of Boros for the final time,
proving to the world who the real top
G is saving the day once again,
along with the famous Mumen rider.
But he's lame, who also helped cycle out
one or two injured citizens and proving
that even if you are useless as shit
when it counts, anyone can be a hero.
And if you want to see a few more wacky
enemies, don't forget to like comment.
Subscribe and check out the
How to Be playlist out below.